elle a ouvert ses portes depuis
septembre 2020 wheel of môme est une
école montessori international et
éco-responsable situé à versailles
quatorze enfants sont accueillis durant
la semaine un établissement créé par
deux femmes dont irina l'auvergnat j'ai
envie de crier une attelle et cole qui à
mon avis n'existe pas parce qu'en plus
de montessori j'amène ma propre culture
j'amène mes propres pensées j'ai voulu
chercher les éducateurs qui convient à
mes
1 et la présentation d'un adulte auprès
des enfants cette école ouverte tous les
jours du lundi au vendredi s'inscrit
dans le cadre de la méthode montessori
sept personnes sont engagées dans ce
projet entrepreneurial l'association
suzanne michaud a accompagné cette
société dans sa phase de création de
bénévoles de l'association suede shoe
l'ont aidé à prendre en main la partie
financière et essaient de structurer son
projet l'association pour favoriser la
création d'entreprises dans les yvelines
a complété l'accompagnement avec un prêt
d'honneur de 50000 euros objectif aider
au démarrage des travaux de l'école
s'ils sont motivés si elles ont la
volonté l'énergie pour mener à bien ce
projet et enfin si l eau si elle
maîtrise les disciplines que doit
posséder un bon entrepreneur du côté de
l'école montessori we love môme une
classe élémentaire pour les élèves de 6
à 12 ans doit ouvrir ses portes en
septembre 2022